hi thanks to the organizers and thanks
to almost all the speakers the exception
being the speakers who I unfortunately
missed so apologies to them the
conference has been excellent Rick
assured me that would be okay to give an
informal talk I've sort of been out of
the area and based on my experience up
in denial I have to conclude that that
was a prank I feel very very her out of
place and I'm kind of wondering if I am
actually starting wonder if I did
something to Rick in which case I
apologize and and now we can can call it
even um so I'm going to be talking about
a question that I have failed to answer
and I should say that Rick asking me to
encourage me to give you some formal
targets worked out very well for me
because in trying to pull the talk
together I figured out a lot of things
that I don't understand and which I
still don't understand but I understand
them I misunderstand them better now so
it's been useful for me you may find
yourself not thanking Rick for
encouraging me to give an informal talk
but but but we'll see where it goes um
this work is done with a lot of people
I'm trying and as you will see failing
to pull together threads that come from
a lot of places and I just want to thank
all of these various people so how many
of you are familiar with are not and the
basic reproductive then there's a little
bit of a cultural gap here okay so
almost everybody but not quite enough
that I can just skip over it so a very
fundamental idea in epidemiology and
mathematical epidemiology comes from
Ronald Ross who is also the person who
discovered or prove that mosquitoes
transmit malaria so very impressive
person apparently impressively obnoxious
as well but the idea is this that if you
can estimate the mean number of new
potential infections per infection you
get a good index of risk at the
population level for this infection to
spread and that there's a threshold what
r us basically did
mathematical calculation based on this
idea and said we don't have to eliminate
mosquitoes from Panama in order to make
malaria go away we have to reduce
mosquito density by eighty percent and
it's going to go away by itself because
there's going to be less than 1
infection for infection so if there's a
hundred infections in this generation
there's going to be 80 in the next and
50 and the next and very strongly
analogous to what you people if I can
use that without offense what many of
you people would call absolute fitness
another important concept is in a
homogeneous Lee mixing population we can
multiply are not by the proportion
susceptible and figure out not how many
people you could infect if you were sick
but how many people you are going to
infect if you're sick the idea being
that if I have three potential
infections but one of you is already
immune to the brand of influence that I
thoughtfully brought along with me to
the meeting I will only be able to
infect the other two and we have a
fairly powerful relationship if we
assume homogeneous mixing and if we
assume i can find out how to use the
laser pointer um are not predicts the
proportion of the population is going to
be affected going to be either infected
or rendered immune by the action of
disease at equilibrium so I started
thinking about all this because we have
been researching canine rabies and in
fact I'm part a small part of a group
that suggests that we can eliminate
canine rabies from all species by cut
targeting domestic dogs that doesn't
mean all kinds of rabies butt canine
rabies is responsible for ninety-nine
percent of the rabies health burden on
humans and the rabies health burden on
humans is steps a substantial compared
to other diseases that spread to humans
primarily from animals rabies has the
most deaths far from the most total
disease burden because far from the most
total disease burden because almost all
the disease burden from rabies is death
whereas leishmaniasis and filariasis
cause a lot of
non fatal disease I was very amused the
first time I saw a picture like this it
was about neglected tropical diseases
and I had been unaware that hat was a
major killer I seem to be the only
person who finds this amusing but oh hi
be the only person who knows what oh
maybe all the person who does it I mean
that's I maybe I thought it was funny
because somebody was presenting it to me
and I was thinking about hats maybe I'm
too had conscious so hat is human after
African trypanosomiasis I guess the
point is I do not want to leave any of
you with the impression that it
represents a hat that is killing I
applaud it so rabies arm I apologize
that this is a table and not a figure
are not estimates for rabies are very
narrow and the better they get and the
more systematically they're done the
narrower the range seems to be and this
is really striking I'll focus on the to
hear that I know the most about I mean
Goran Goro district and the serengeti
district which are two very different
places there next to each other and we
chose them specifically for contrast
serengeti is very agricultural rural is
what you might picture is a good place
for rabies there's homesteads and little
aggregations and villages Goren gore was
very pastoralist it's a kind of place
that's much more strange to me than an
African rural thing and the density of
people the density of dogs the kinds of
interactions all seem to be much lower
and yet using very similar methods we
got very similar estimates of are not
and it's a mystery it's a mystery that
these estimates are narrow because if
you reduce the density of dogs by a
factor of five and if we've shown that
dogs biting other dogs is what spreads
the rabies why would that not have a big
effect on the spread of rabies and it's
a mystery that they're low in general i
learned i think from martin novak that
if you know something is bigger than
something else in general it typically
means it's much bigger right and it's
don't generally expect to find
not near one but here we find it near
one um for a wide range of values and
I'm just going to take a digression and
talk about this is actually this narrow
bands of are not are a typical pattern
and disease but for a reason it doesn't
seem to work for rabies that we haven't
been able to make work for rabies so how
did we met okay how did we measure our
not in the with contact tracing its
amazing Katie hampson went out and she
got to know veterinary officers and
agricultural field extension officers
and she talked to people who have been
bitten by rabid dogs and went backwards
and forwards in time and started hiring
people and she knows people and so we've
traced and when i say we i contributed
to the tracing of one or two dogs maybe
by a factor of one or two percent so
they so there's there's a i guess i'm
slipping in this direction when I say I
did something I mean we did it and when
I say we did something I mean I mean
they did it so using those definitions
um we trace seventy or eighty percent of
the raid cases that had ever been
reported we asked people who do you
think bit your dog who do you think your
dog bit back forth up and down and we
also have estimation methods and it's
all on a paper um there are other models
that fit from say epidemic curves when
something is introduced and maybe we can
go back to this just because that's
exciting I've pushed a button to start
the timer but I didn't succeed in
starting the timer so I don't know
whether on my head or behind oh there
you are um least I know where to look if
I get too far behind um so a good
question which I hope will have time to
get back to if you remain interested the
main reason that you see patterns like
this is because of heterogeneity so a
long time ago I thought about gonorrhea
and the fact that if you go around the
world to big cities you see or you saw
back when I was paying attention pearl
of gonorrhea from about five percent to
about twenty percent in the adults
sexually active population which if you
believe the naive models implies a very
just the same problem as rate it's a
very small and narrow possible band for
our not that would give you those
prevalences and the case of gonorrhea
the answer is very well known it's due
to heterogeneity in human sexual
behavior and if you allow simply for the
fact that some people are having a lot
of sex and some people are having less
sex so if you imagine two populations
normal human populations one of which is
using a lot of condoms one which is not
using a lot of condoms or one of which
has some sort of good immune background
to fight off gonorrhea and the other one
doesn't if you imagine these populations
is heterogeneous one of them is going to
have a much higher prevalence of
gonorrhea in reality human sexual
behavior is one of most highly variable
things that a biologist can study and in
reality if you go to either of these
places you're going to find a fairly big
group of highly sexually active people
who have gonorrhea despite whether or
not they're in the high-risk city of the
low-risk city and a fairly large group
of lowest people who don't have
gonorrhea despite what city they're in
and despite what they're exposed to and
so this smooths out these curves and
it's sort of a pervasive explanation for
patterns like this but we can't make it
work for rabies and one of the reasons
is that this really works by
correlations between what's going on
with susceptible what's going on with
with infectious individuals and the key
thing which I find very interesting
about rabies is not shared by a lot of
disease is a fundamental asymmetry and
how its spread right typically if I have
sex with you you're having sex with me
right or if what you have flu I might
get it I have flu you might get it but
rabies doesn't work like that right
there's no straightforward argument that
i can make whereby a dog that's more
likely to give you rabies the kind of
dog that gets furious rabies and bites
lots of dogs there's no obvious reason
why that dog would be more likely to get
rabies there's a fundamental asymmetry
between biting and getting bitten and
there's not anything known that could
explain this flat
in rabies even though we see that kind
of flattening a lot of other diseases so
I started thinking about it as an
evolutionary puzzle from the point of
view of the bug and so I'm going to talk
a little bit about what people think
about how diseases evolve and so there's
a well-established theory which many of
you have heard of and many of you've
also probably heard the refutation to
all apologize for the boring parts of
the talk the idea that pathogen should
evolve to get along with us right if
they're not annoying us or killing us or
getting our immune system too excited we
can all live and be happy together we
carry them along that's the commensal
theory here's a photograph of a kid with
the common cold who is seems and feels
fine he's being carried around he's
playing with this other kid who happy to
report did not get the cold on that
particular occasion um and so that's one
theory of how pathogens can evolve when
people started questioning this
quantitatively they came actually to a
very pretty theory which is an
ecological theory of susceptibles as a
resource so the idea is going all the
way back to the curve and the idea that
the number of susceptibles is going to
converge at equilibrium in a well-mixed
population 21 / are not so that means
the pathogen or the pathogen strain with
the highest are not can use up almost
all the susceptibles and out-compete all
the other strengths there's not enough
susceptibles so this is an example of a
Joshua Tree this is an example of an
organism winning by drawing down the
resource in this case water right
there's no trees around this tree
because it's drawn down the water level
with its root system to a level where
nothing else can survive and the idea of
pathogen trade-offs theory is
susceptible to that resource and the
original idea it's a fascinating theory
the original idea was all from the host
center point of view why does the bug
want or not want to kill us and it was
articulated and often referred to as if
your avirulence a theory of how deadly
or damaging diseases are but it really
works a lot better to think about it
from the bugs point of view and the bug
doesn't actually care if it kills us the
bug cares or sorry doesn't care whether
it kills us or whether we just get
immune to it the bug cares for how long
you can sit around and make a living and
so instead of virulent I think this is
the wrong word unfortunately I have some
guests um instead of virulent it's
better to think about in terms of how
aggressively the pathogen is trying to
invade your body whether by shooting
toxins at you or whether by reproducing
more quickly and the tradeoff theory is
fairly straightforward I think I skip
very lightly over my conceptualization
of our not which is that it is the
product my conceptualization for this
talk which is the product of a
transmission rate so beta has units of 1
over time and it's the rate at which I
can make people sick with my flu right
so if I'm going to well mixed population
back at my university maybe I'm going to
make one average one half of a person
sick per day and the other component of
our not is here towel although I always
call it D obviously vandals have been
editing my talk um towel or D which is a
time length right and so beta is a half
of an average rate or an average hazard
of infecting half a person per day and
tau is I'm symptomatically infectious
with the flu for four days and so the
product is a unitless number or not
which ties back to some of the other
nonsense that I've been telling you and
the idea is is the pathogen gets more
aggressive it has a higher sorry as the
pathogen gets did I do it right more
aggressive it has a higher average beta
right it's
replicating more sending out more
viruses or whatever but that saturates
right I can't infect people who I don't
see no matter how many flu virions I
have it in fact you could imagine model
where this turns over I'm too sick to go
around and get you sick and as the
pathogen is more aggressive it has on
average a lower cow either because it's
going to kill me or take me out of
circulation or it's going to piss off my
immune system to the extent where I kill
it which to it is again for most
pathogens basically the same thing and
so we get our not which is what the
joshua tree is trying to maximize has a
hump in the middle and this could be a
good starting point for thinking about
why some are not values are clustered
close to one but like the first set of
ideas i threw at you it also doesn't
work very well on for rabies and i'm
going to take another digression so this
is a Wolverine which is a small animal
which can kill larger animals and does
anybody know or care to guess what this
is I wouldn't know so there's really no
reason why I should even ask you that I
know because I googled in fact I don't
know somebody this could be a chain of
misinformation about bacteria this is
anthrax and anthrax is a classic
counterexample to what I just told you
anthrax ecologically speaking is not a
parasite but at a predator because
anthrax does not spread at all virtually
ever unless it kills you so anthrax does
not have the same trade off that we were
talking about anthrax as it increases
its aggressiveness it's increasing both
tau the amount of arm sorry as it
increases this aggressiveness it's
increasing both tally amount of time and
has a chance to expose you and as well
as beta right the idea here is that if
anthrax not aggressive at night enough
it might fail to kill you and you might
have a towel of zero and we average that
in and the point is that
things that want to kill you don't have
the same trade off now rabies isn't
quite there right rabies spreads while
you're alive but it spreads while you're
very sick and it's not at all obvious
that rabies has a downward-sloping towel
that is to say on average you're going
to have less chance to give people
rabies if the rabies just kind of chills
in you yo how goes up his aggressiveness
goes up it seems like it's so like
facing for anthrax so yeah the idea for
anthrax and I stumbled over because I
hadn't thought of the problem until I
got to it at least not recently the idea
for anthrax is that this is really a
couple weeks of your being a carcass
people are typically thinking about
antelopes in the savanna multiplied by
the probability going to write because
that's what it needs to do so the more
aggressively its spreads inside you the
higher the chance it's going to kill you
and the more bacteria you're probably
gonna happen to us um so a lot of
problems I'm having a lot of problems
with the narrow rabies arnotts and
particularly those in Tanzania because
those are the ones I understand a lot of
what I've told you has been based on
doing Oh Dee models which make
assumptions make assumption that we have
a lot of water molecules and that
they're well mix right and so up until
now I've assumed that the population is
well mixed and that's critical for this
Joshua Tree theory it's critical for the
idea that the pathogen that wins is
going to be the one that kicks the most
hosts out of the susceptible pool
because it's easy to imagine as soon as
we don't have perfect mixing you can
imagine there's a disadvantage to using
up all the resources right around you
there's probably a good analogy here to
human affairs and economics which would
be one to get into and so I was
fascinated at some point in my life when
I connected my concerns about rabies and
how it seems to regulate its are not
which I should state clearly right
and other possibilities that were still
just wrong about the rabies are not and
it's not that narrow but this seemed
like a cool lead to pursue people talk
about how pathogens may limit their own
are not may limit in some sense their
own short-term fitness in space through
simple evolutionary processes so I'm
sorry I meant to blow this up and make a
nice PDF but instead of my computer
cried sorry I met to put this at the
right scale but my computer crashed
instead and I gave up I've had a lot of
adventures here and I don't know how
much time I have because the adventures
I had failing to pull this talk together
probably more interesting than the talk
um and the two ideas that seem to flow
through at least my understanding of
this idea of spatially self-limiting
pathogens are one the idea that these
things develop some sort of
characteristic frequency complicated
spatio-temporal stuff that I don't
really understand and the other is
something called burnout the idea that a
pathogen that uses up all of the
susceptibles in a particular environment
or locale Mike go extinct because it's
got no more except susceptibles so here
is an example of a simple disease model
and it's a caricature of how until
recently I thought about burnout so we
have this is measles invading Iceland
except it's and a fake Iceland in my
computer that's even smaller and more
homogeneous than the realizin and what
you get so these are the susceptibles
and what you get is a very fast and very
sharp epidemic and by the end of a few
weeks in real life in less than two
weeks in fake life um you have virtually
no susceptibles left right everybody who
could get measles has gotten me as you
that is this violent epidemic and the
idea also borne out by it by measles in
Iceland is that it's then going to go
extinct meisel
used to go extinct and Iceland and now
they have airplanes so it doesn't
although it may now again because of
this other thing but i like that i'm
taking the digression from my digression
if i take unlabeled digressions you
should call me on it because it's a real
danger so the idea is one of the things
i wanted to think about is good rabies
be regulating its aggressiveness by
through local bernal and we're going to
come back to the ideas of bernal we're
going to come back to picture oh I meant
to mention that in the simplest epidemic
model the number of susceptible is left
after a violent epidemic is on order of
e to the minus or not right so if
measles has an R naught of 20 then you
can imagine in a well-mixed model every
single person on earth would get measles
whereas if rabies has an R naught of two
there would still be some susceptibles
left and that might turn out to be good
for the disease so we made us a set a
simple model inspired very strongly by
the pnas paper that I showed you not so
clearly so we have a square grid sorry
we have a square grid everybody's got
eight neighbors that they can infect and
this talent d or synonyms in my poor
little brain this should say beta and D
can evolve freely so beta is the
transmission rate d is the duration of
infectiousness and we just put this
thing on a lattice um and the first
thing we do because it's what the people
who came up with this idea so I'd like
to stress a that everything some of this
stuff i'm going to show you next few
minutes is is pretty cool but it's
mostly us replicating and maybe slightly
generalizing what was already done I'm
just trying to understand it the coolest
stuff was was definitely known before I
came along but if you provide the thing
with fixed time courses meaning that if
I get rabies today either some
characteristic kind of infectiousness
I'm going to follow it exactly I'm
supposed to be sick for one point three
days I'm going to be sick for one point
three days and if I'm supposed to be
resistant or if my cell is supposed to
be resistant before some other dog is
recruited by the family for two months
then resistance is well as for exactly
two months so that's what i mean by
fixed time course and what happens is
something that's absolutely remarkable
which is you introduce the disease it's
some barely able to scrape by level and
of course both beta the infectiousness
and PAL the duration of infectiousness
increase and then for no obvious reason
we put no trade offs or nothing into the
model towel suddenly turns around and
end digesting endogenously excuse me
decides to get smaller and it does so in
such a way that are not is regulated to
a characteristic value and this value is
going to depend on the details of the
lattice or the network that you put it
on and it seems really cool and I don't
understand so one of the many adventures
I had in trying to prepare this talk arm
was that we had some movies of this
process and I'm color blind and the
movies were supposed to have color but
the color parameters were set wrong and
I kept asking people to help me identify
color patterns and some of the people
were able to identify color patterns
even though they were not present and
it's turned into a very large of and
confusing things so at four o'clock this
morning I decided to give up what yeah I
had four o'clock this morning I had
given up in the interest of my own
saturday night at four o'clock this
morning I got up and I made a PDF fake
movie
so let's see so this is what I don't
know what do you go for the board um so
this is what the thing is doing with
fixed time courses um it evolves to have
these wave so what you're seeing here um
the black cells are resistant they can't
get sick the blue cells are susceptible
um and the non black or blue cells are
the range of evolving ah pathogens which
are occupying hosts I always think about
the bug first it's a big problem um and
the color is like a heat map why are the
faster pathogens which are the ones um i
guess i guess the ones that are favored
more than we expected easier what is
that red are the ones that should be
fitter and what I've done is I've color
coded from red to white sort of based on
this quasi equilibrium so it has to go
from red to white and yeah so are not
but even worth it there's no trade-off
in this model ah one other thing to
simplify this I froze beta so here we're
now froze beta so everybody's got the
same infections the only difference
between the red and the white is that
the red are infectious for longer so in
any simple model you could conceptualize
the red are just going to spread out and
take over the white but in reality they
have these insane patterns with these
vortices and you can spend a long time
looking at them I think and not
understand them could certainly spend a
long time looking at them and not
understanding them if the colors are not
there but now they definitely are and we
can come back to these patterns maybe if
we have time but yes
yes look yeah the red should be winning
and is not in fact there are quasi
equilibrium hill yeah so why is it that
black are the black turned blue and this
with the fixed time course you get these
very regular waves so the black turned
blue just in time to get eaten you know
thank you oh okay um so yeah a lot of
confusion going on where is my talk it
disappeared is that it you seem to have
been cursed experiments for phage I'm
going to save that until the question
area but i can i can give away that the
answer is no so we did these experiments
and they have they had these travelers
and it seems very fragile i was looking
for Brian I wasn't looking for perfect
spatial synchronicity because I've been
to serengeti district and it's not in
fact a square lattice right and so when
we first did these experiments here's
where it all devolves into chaos in case
it wasn't chaotic enough before we first
did these experiments it seemed very
fragile it seem to depend on the fixed
time course but when I was trying to
review and sort of do everything
carefully and Marshall my thoughts for
this talk i find that actually you can
get this phenomenon with non ridiculous
um parameters in terms of variation so
here SD log is the standard sigma
parameter for the log normal
distribution and as we increase as d log
um this phenomenon goes away so at first
I was not interested in but it doesn't
go away super fast so we have even for
an SD log of 2 we have something looks
qualitatively like the same phenomenon
and if I have time and there's interest
I'll show you that movie which I literal
created between nine and nine-thirty
this morning because I if I hadn't
thought my talk but start at nine I
wouldn't have had that movie um so so
that the time course is time for
assuming it's both time courses are
logged with with this is one parameter
what's the other one the other parameter
is roughly what's evolving so we have we
fix the recalcitrant period and then the
other two time parameters are evolving
and so here beta has units one over time
and then the duration is just in units
of the recalcitrant people will have to
yeah this is the other prominent oh and
in the other case it's one and that's
that's the thing that's evolving that's
that's the key so what we've done is
we've taken these fixed time periods
which kept everything the same and we
just smooth them smush them out the
obvious moon and again qualitatively
similar and then as you increase on the
variance it just poof disappears and you
get a very sharp phase transition to
chaos and to something that looks like a
lot of local burnout so it's all to me
very interesting um and I'll try to tie
this all together it's also come in my
mind together with other thoughts about
how and when burnout occurs um and
questions as you are asking about these
time distributions so the conventional
wisdom has to do with what I show you
that big it's very appealing and it
seems to be largely but not entirely
wrong and I'm part of the conventional
wisdom this is a paper um that I was
involved in it that's been influential
the conventional wisdom is these big
epidemics tend to lead to burnout this
is a paper where we claim to show that
with some simulations
although at the time and again in
retrospect the most surprising thing
about these is not that we were able to
show what we already believe but how
narrow some of our little pictures of
how reducing the effect of our not can
increase pathogen persistence what's
really surprising is how narrow some of
these windows are but anyway we publish
this and we claimed and people believe
that this is a mechanism for how's Ellen
otic diseases get established thank you
that zilla not a disease this is nipah
virus that we said it probably had to
jump to Pig several times because the
first time it jumped two pigs it
probably burned out and the second time
was probably more likely to persist that
may be true but it's not true in the
simple way that we thought just recently
David urn decided that people hadn't
done this systematically enough and he
and I and about 10 other people went
back and did sort of the simplest
possible simulations you can do and we
found the opposite we found that
increasing are not always increases your
probability that a disease is going to
invade sort of the opposite of this
conventional wisdom and if you look at
it and if you look at the sde we
shouldn't be so impressed by how big
this peak is and by how low this trough
of susceptibles are what people tend not
to notice is that at least in the simple
model the infectious individuals don't
necessarily reach a low trough and the
fact is that if you're a pathogen and
you need to survive the winter loosely
speaking that is to say the period of
time after you burned out all your hosts
it doesn't matter that to you that much
if there's one in a hundred or one in a
thousand or one in a hundred thousand
susceptible hosts at the trough what
matters is how long it takes those hosts
to recover back to where you're going to
be able to make a living again and that
depends on are not in the other
direction right so if I have an iron lot
of three I might leave 120 susceptible
hosts giving me an effective are of
three over 20 but then I have to wait a
third of their constituent period to
make a living if I have an art out of 20
I get down to know susceptible hosts but
unless I'm absolutely killing all of
them I only have to wait one twentieth
of the recalcitrant period and I'm back
in business and that intuition that I
just gave you produces with two
equations a picture that looks like this
and does a suspiciously good job of
matching this picture and I happen to
know that there was no cheating involved
so you can choose to or not to take my
word for it in the interest of time i'll
skip lightly over what I think since I
don't understand anything about how the
time distributions might play into this
right so until netic the best understood
results are those from Van Baldwin who
uses an absolutely fixed time period and
from David earn who does the opposite
he's using a purely exponential time
period for everything and they can play
a lot of games in between those areas so
I feel like I've left thank you the
problem of these rabies the mystery of
the of these rabies are knots um
beautifully intact I don't even know if
its evolutionary but I do want to make
one final suggestion I like pursuing the
evolutionary path I again I thank Rick
for sort of like making me get my head
and order it everybody else's expense um
but another thing that occurs to be
trying to do it maybe evolution
operating at a wider scale so here are
the best rabies data that we could
collect from all of Africa about five or
ten years ago and here's a model in
which we purported to show that the time
scale of rabies fluctuation is best
explained by people panicking and then
not panicking there's no way to get
these things to go as fast as they look
like they go if not for the fact that
when you have a rabies epidemic people
react to it and that could conceivably
be an evolutionary pressure to bigger
times at a bigger spatial scale than
I've been able to think about
I often think about drop this partly cuz
Katya is here I often think about
influenza and all this airborne but
airborne virus surveillance right so
when h1n1 came out ontario stopped
certain people from entering ontario and
at the time it seemed ridiculous because
i knew and kaity knew that flu was what
that the absolute was going to sleep the
globe the question that occurred to be
later is if you stop the people with the
fever in the cough from getting off the
airplane does that give the milder flus
a chance to get to Ontario before the
worst foods do and is that a way in
which we're affecting pathogen evolution
who are not even trying to and my time
is up so thank you for your patience I
did not need to do that time for
questions these patterns in the
simulation that showed they seemed
rather typical of sort of cyclical
cellular automata right I we do sort of
spiral patterns yes spiral patterns look
typical to a lot of people I'm not an
expert in the area but yeah I would love
to know how you get those more to season
why there seem to be patterns that
basically what it looks like to me now
that I've been able to see the colors
for less dollars um what it looks like
to me is that the whites that is to say
the slower nominal vestment ones are
somehow staying inside the vortices and
the things are getting red as they move
away and eventually annihilate
themselves in the susceptible yeah I'd
love to know so more recently and this
has been studied a lot in the context of
what people call what paper scissors
yeah so i have read those failures of
three species that have the sort of
cyclical dominance and then
you get you know patterns that look
exactly like that so I think there must
be some you know some structure like
that in Europe right answer so and of
course in some sense that's what we want
to get away from right whatever is it
artefactual are very specific is less
what I'm interested although not sure
I'm going to achieve that laudable goal
following up on your mark maybe you can
get these patterns even without the head
of romaine I think it's more that the
the time to come back to being
susceptible is pretty slow and I think
that horse is the thing to make these
wave patterns in order to cope with it
if we came back and more quickly then
you could get some random mess but you
know it sir has to organize itself
because it takes a long time to go back
from the remove to the susceptible and
because of this regularity that the
blues I mean in this case it's super
clear and that looks very artefactual
you know that I'm getting susceptible
just as I'm about to get infected I
become susceptible so that it works and
what's interesting to me is if I could
find so this is going to work so this
one much less smooth but still seems to
work so this is the one with the log
Sigma or whatever I'm supposed to call
it of 0.2 which until recently we
thought did before and it's still
possible
right before in law now you can see it's
messier and yet still seems to generate
the vortices but I think a good point is
i'd love to understand the vortices I'm
not ever going to do as well as the
people who do that for a living what I
really want to understand is why it's
ever good to be what and why when it's
good to be white it's right there in the
vortex and I think as you approach this
phase transition you see um a burnout
sort of burnout sort of sweeps the world
and Mike really play I mean this might
really turn out to royally ticked about
different ways didn't really seem to
take over you the whites can't take over
because I've colored it so that suspect
this is a this is it a suit
quasi-equilibrium I've colored it so
that I have arranged from white to it
you can look at it sort of together with
the time course and you'll see that it
went oh like it but we're going to be
difficult French for this beta this is
this is the ring and the point being of
course than what you would expect is for
the Reds to take over and to get redder
and rather another if I like them but
they don't but the color maps the same
across images know the color map is not
the same facilities today color map is
tuned to the image so that I can see
what's going on in that image and a
relative column on deck sort of changing
so I can tell you exactly what it is
pure Braves buddies not change your time
it's constant with time it was time
because it's already let it go to
equilibrium that's well and record
because I make a concept of time but not
between yeah there be any point
emotional process sorry news from Texas
yes that's that's absolutely one of the
next things to do the other thing to do
which we started is to d regular eyes
the network a little bit a big problem
is d regularizing the network is that
you don't get such nice pictures that's
one what reason to commotion term trend
of not increasing in deep pretty low by
not only considering and what the are
not is an individual in what woods what
its offspring spread out or not these
aren't so you can imagine that I'm in
this setting you know you have let's say
you have one of two costumes one that
has a longer duration of affection on
the short duration of affection the one
of the longer duration infections have
immediately at higher are not crazy
Salem right but if you look at their
most reviewed some spatial setting
basically the offspring this high one
might not actually might burn self kind
of shrine itself becomes recovers and so
forth so busy its offspring up or not
are not the bars right and whereas other
one so basically you take Pat um I was
like a kin selection sort of basically
know people are young executives people
their generation people you know I sort
of came to this backwards because i was
starting with you know ray busy college
and I've sort of been drifting into this
direction but people have done and that
big arguments about Wilson and Wilson
the famous controversial paper they
dipped into this and now people are
attacking them so yes this is the answer
people do kin selection but I don't know
if anybody's done this sort of
grandchildren are effective which I like
okay
having those ways it turns out that
session IDs dick behavior unlike you two
all right and for relations and that's I
mean that's the big question in my mind
is how fragile is and when I thought it
was a little more fragile when I thought
it broke even here I had a whole
different topic which is you know this
is an artifact and but the more I tried
to nail down that it's fragile in the
last couple weeks he's the more I got
confused and I took that loop through
the burnout thing just happened to be
going on at the same time thinking long
ways as long as unit goes wait ok
probably we can take something else to
provide special structure last question
quick quick comment on what country said
them sometimes in these social network
model yeah stretching for sexually
transmitted diseases you have people
with higher sexual activity
preferentially sort of attached to other
people i think so i think that might
make suggesting okay thank you